[inaudible]
have you ever tried shave ice? That's right. Shave ice,
that snowy powdery treat served around Hawaii.
Some shops even use homemade flavors, extracted straight from local fruits.
It's a great antidote to the heat and humidity.
So let's say you're giving me directions to a worthy shave. I shop.
Here's a map for you. I'm here and the shop is, oh,
right around here. How do I get there?
Whether or not you're aware of it,
the way you answered that question says a lot about how you've been taught to
speak about directions in your language. Take two directions, systems,
cardinal directions and relative directions. If you're American,
European or Chinese, cardinal directions are probably second nature to you.
You imagine a map with a fixed north at the top eastern west to the sides and
south at the bottom.
So you tell me to go north and then east until I see the storefront.
There's another way to get me there.
You can direct me from my own point of view. Instead,
this gets called egocentric direction.
Putting yourself in my shoes, you'll tell me to turn to my left.
Then go forward. Then make a right turn and go straight again until I've arrived
so far. I'm not really telling you anything you don't already know,
but you're in Hawaii now.
And the language here lets you get around without the systems.
The main directions are Mocha towards the mountains or MCI towards the sea.
Mar means towards Lukas Land and Kai is sea.
So the shave ice is milk of the library.
I'm currently MCI of the shopping center, so I need to walk Mocha to get there.
Notice that the MOCA MCI system isn't egocentric if you're standing here in the
sea is here, but the mountains are there. This way is Malkin.
No matter which way you turn,
it's unlike cardinal directions to north is north.
No matter where you are on the island, but,
and Mocha depend on your current location.
So mocha and Mckayla are unique geographical directions.
This is one of many unique quirks I've found in my journeys.
Check out the playlist for more travel vignettes on words and places.
And thank you for learning with them. [inaudible].